okay speaking of computational
irreducibility okay wolfram thinks free
will is tied to that i'm curious
but the way that he you the way that he
defines free will i don't think is the
way that most people would think
of the word free will being defined
more that you can't predict your own
actions it has to do with predictivity
either way do you believe that people
have free will
or do you believe that you have free
will let's say that
you're asking the hard questions today
what i think is that
the idea of free will
the question do i have free will
is
uh it takes as assumptions backgrounding
the for the question to make sense
it requires a picture
of reality that is too simple
and that by the time you develop a
picture of reality that is sophisticated
enough
that question kind of doesn't make sense
anymore
i'm not claiming that i'm
at that level of understanding of
reality but i am saying
um
yeah can you explain to me the simple
background assumptions that go into a
question like that and then how with
more articulated assumptions or more
advanced assumptions that dissolves the
question i mean i i feel like this is
ground that has been covered
at least okay i mean i don't know i'm
often very unsatisfied by discussions
about about these topics but um
the problem is to do to do a convincing
explanation on this requires going into
a lot of like subtopics that
if people who who haven't heard them
before hear them first from me i'm not
going to give a particularly convincing
version of them because it's not my
shtick i don't go around
talking about free will but
there are for example um things you can
google that'll give you good starting
points so for example
there's a thing called
um
the the second time around problem right
which is that
uh
it seems to be
indistinguishable
whether
uh
like this is the first time things were
happening and we chose what could happen
or whether it's a fully deterministic
playback
of that and so that's a simpler question
that you could start with like
how would i even know the difference
between those two things because
in the first time around
so our
our reasons for believing we have free
will are the primary one is that we feel
like it right we feel like we have free
will
um
maybe the first time we felt like we had
free will because we had free will right
um but the second time it's a
reproduction of the first time so we
have to feel the same way or it's not a
good reproduction
but it's a deterministic reproduction so
it's not like we could have changed our
mind right and so
thinking about a simpler sub problem
like that is much easier than thinking
about the problem of
the actual whole universe that we're in
right now
um but by thinking about smaller
problems like that
you can broaden your horizons in a
certain way you can broaden the scope of
things
that you
think about
right
um and so
in that second time around problem kind
of case it's unclear whether you had
free will or not because
which one of those are you in the
original or the replay changes the
answer but then it's exactly the same
experience in both of them so
uh
is that one experience or two
experiences do you even know right
do they like map to the same thing or
are they two separate right
um another another um
dang oh you know so for people who know
a bit of quantum mechanics right you
know that there are
uh
the everettians have become
quite well represented currently um in
terms of the way that people interpret
what's happening and the way to
interpret things from an evaredian
standpoint is
that just
all things that can happen do happen
right
and so
what does it mean to have free will in
that case it doesn't mean what people
naively think determinism means which is
that only one thing happens and must
happen it's like no
actually a bunch of things happen but
then does it
maybe
like maybe the question of free will is
orthogonal to that in some sense
anyway
because it changes the waiting on how
much of things happen or not like it's
unclear but so i think that
rather than trying to answer this
question directly of do we have free
will i think the best that people can do
right now is like go to the gym and work
out right
and like pump some iron get buff and
come back later and answer these
questions
um
do you mean that metaphorically go to
the gym
yeah but you know it might help
non-metaphorically as well um
[Music]
so what do you mean metaphorically by
that you mean go study philosophy go
live your life go
try and develop a skill
i mean if you're if you're interested in
the question of free will then
thinking about these sub problems
i think can very quickly get you at
least to a point where you realize why
the the question as originally posed is
too simple to really make sense
but that's then been replaced by all
these possibilities of how things could
be
are those possibilities fictional are
they real
that's
sort of the material you would be
contending with
um in that domain but then
um
then there's maybe equivalent questions
that are something like do i have free
will but that are
um
more answerable and maybe more specific
right